y
[Música]
en eeuu acusó a rusia de planear una
operación de bandera falsa para
justificar una invasión a ucrania el
kremlin aseguró que los señalamientos
son falsos las declaraciones se
presentan al tiempo que el gobierno de
kiev denunció un ciberataque contra
páginas estatales tenemos análisis el
tenista serbio novak djokovic enfrentará
a las autoridades migratorias
australianas en las próximas horas
después de que su visa fuera cancelada
por segunda vez de cara al inicio del
abierto de australia el deportista corre
el riesgo de ser deportado el presidente
de serbia acusó al primer ministro
australiano de maltratar al atleta
se profundiza la crisis para el primer
ministro británico gordon son su
gobierno se disculpó formalmente ante la
reina isabel segunda por dos fiestas
celebradas el pasado 16 de abril en la
víspera del funeral del príncipe felipe
mientras el país estaba de luto
buenas tardes para todos bienvenidos a
esta emisión de noticias en france24 soy
valentina torre sánchez iniciamos con la
denuncia de eeuu que asegura que rusia
está creando excusas para poder invadir
a ucrania puntualmente el portavoz del
pentágono john kirby aseguró que moscú
está trabajando en un ataque de falsa
bandera es decir una operación diseñada
para que parezca un ataque en su contra
como pretexto para invadir a ucrania
como si fuera una retaliación el kremlin
negó los señalamientos que llegan el
mismo día en que quiere denunció un
ciberataque masivo contra varios sitios
del gobierno de ucrania asegura que hay
indicios de que rusia sería responsable
del hackeo los hechos se producen
después de que concluyeran sin avances
las reuniones que han mantenido rusia y
la otan donde se rechazaron las
exigencias en materia de seguridad del
presidente vladimir putin de acabar con
la política de puertas abiertas en el
organismo
para analizar este tema conectamos con
luis alberto villamarín él es
especialista en defensa nacional
estrategia y geopolítica bienvenido a
france 24 que tan creíbles son las
declaraciones de eeuu sobre este ataque
fabricado que estaría planeando rusia
gracias valentina son completamente
creíbles porque es el estilo de los
manuales soviéticos que aplica muy bien
el señor putin de causar terror de
generar el caos de trasladar la
responsabilidad a terceros y de lograr
su objetivo que es el de posicionarse
fuerte y presionar que en las
conversaciones que continuarán la
próxima semana
la otan y eeuu se dan a sus intenciones
pero lo mencionábamos anteriormente
estas declaraciones ocurren mientras
quiero denunciar un ciberataque masivo
la otan anunció que firmaría un acuerdo
con ucrania para una mayor cooperación
en ciberdefensa que le daría a ucrania
acceso al sistema militar de occidente
para compartir información sobre
programas maliciosos como se espera que
reaccione moscú ante este nuevo
acercamiento
no podemos conseguir a en su propuesta
en su proyecto estratégico su intención
que tiene porque desde luego lo han
trazado como un plan a largo plazo como
un programa de acciones y de
métodos para presionar y para lograr que
la otan no acepte a ucrania ni cranea se
vincule ya la otan y de esta forma
presionarán constantemente en todos los
ámbitos diplomáticos geopolíticos e
internacionales y amenazaran con hacer
acciones en diferentes partes del mundo
para que
todos los miembros de la otan y eeuu
sean las intenciones y desde luego
negarán siempre la participación en este
tipo de acciones que son muy propias de
los manuales soviéticos y de la
mentalidad invasiva que maneja el
ejecutivo se puede hablar de un fracaso
en los diálogos con rusia es decir
recordemos que la ofc advirtió que
existe el mayor riesgo de guerra en 30
años que se puede esperar de esta crisis
pues se puede esperar muy poco se podría
decir que inicialmente la primera semana
si fue un fracaso porque las
declaraciones del vicecanciller russia
rus o perdón fueron muy agresivas fueron
desafiantes fueron esa doble moral de
que queremos estar en paz y queremos
hablar pero si no se hace lo que yo digo
no no avanzamos es decir con cara gano
yo yo he consejo pierde usted no se ve
que haya un logro efectivo de parte de
la otan las posiciones son muy cambiadas
estados unidos y la otan dicen en lo que
quieren es hacer los tratados vigentes e
inclusive rusia ya incumplió sobre armas
sobre posiciones militares y sobre
entrenamiento militar y maniobras
conjuntas y rociar lo que hiciste es que
ucrania pues sigue siendo bajo su órbita
y que no hay forma de cambiar su punto
de vista sino que ucrania quede bajo su
órbita sí
simplemente acceda a lo que dice señor
villa no hay na usted muchas gracias por
su análisis y por compartirlo con
nosotros en france24 en otras noticias
el tenista serbio novak djokovic fue
detenido por las autoridades migratorias
australianas después de que su visa
fuera cancelada por segunda vez por
motivos de salud y por el interés
público se espera que el número 1 del
tenis mundial comparezca ante una corte
federal que decidirá si es deportado el
gobierno decidió no proceder con su
deportación hasta que culmine el proceso
de apelación impulsado por el serbio
entretanto el presidente de serbia acusó
al primer ministro de australia scott
morrison de maltratar al deportista
la declaración del primer ministro
australiano scott morrison diciendo que
está feliz y que acoge con satisfacción
la decisión de cancelar una visa para un
tenista el número 1 del mundo el serbio
novak djokovic estoy asombrado por el
hecho que tales decisiones puedan ser
tomadas por los poderes ejecutivos del
gobierno después de que el tribunal haya
tomado la suya
el primer ministro británico boris
johnson afronta su mayor crisis de
liderazgo hasta la fecha el gobierno se
disculpó formalmente con la reina isabel
segunda por dos fiestas que se
realizaron en la sede oficial del
ejecutivo el pasado 16 de abril la
víspera del funeral del príncipe felipe
cuando el país estaba de luto la
revelación se suma a la de otra fiesta
en el jardín del número 10 de downing
street en la que si participo johnson
cada vez más miembros del partido
conservador piden un voto de censura
contra su líder a continuación los
últimos detalles sobre este caso
puede boris johnson seguir al frente del
gobierno británico esa pregunta se ha
vuelto cada día menos tabú las últimas
acusaciones el daily telegraph reveló
que downing street estuvo de fiesta en
la víspera del funeral del príncipe
felipe de edimburgo el año pasado esa
misma noche la reina isabel estuvo sola
de luto debido a las reglas de
confinamiento un acto por el que este
viernes la oficina de johnson pidió
disculpas pero que no logró calmar los
ánimos incluso entre sus propios colegas
conservadores
en que creo que como todo aquel que leyó
esta historia esta mañana me sorprendió
me sorprendió leerla subir a este es un
momento particularmente sombrío por
supuesto para todos por todo nuestro
país toda la nación compartió con su
majestad su vestido
creo que los eventos que tuvieron lugar
esa noche fueron totalmente inaceptables
y completamente insensibles y nunca
debieron haber sucedido
roger gay él estaba entre varios
parlamentarios que han confirmado
públicamente su intención de castigar a
johnson si el 15% de los diputados
conservadores lo hace habrá un voto de
censura que puede terminar con su
expulsión pero downing street- sugiere a
los británicos furiosos sucedido pasar
la página
el primer ministro se disculpó el
miércoles fue muy claro en cuanto a que
se han cometido errores pero sí creo que
debemos analizar la posición general en
la que nos encontramos como país creo
que debemos seguir adelante y hablar
sobre cómo vamos a resolver nuestros
problemas boris johnson reconoció haber
asistido a una fiesta en mayo de 2020
argumentando que pensaba que era un
evento de trabajo varias protestas
antigubernamentales en túnez que
violaron las restricciones porque hoy 19
terminaron en enfrentamientos violentos
con la policía este viernes los
manifestantes acusan al presidente de
caixa y de perpetrar un presunto golpe
de estado por haber suspendido al
parlamento y querer reescribir la
constitución del país veamos el reporte
de jorge hurtado
nuevas protestas sacuden túnez pese a
que el gobierno de caixa y el prohibió
las manifestaciones argumentando un
aumento de contagios de kobe 19 el
partido islamista enhada convocó una
marcha en su contra
hoy en el aniversario de la revolución
tunecina de impedir que nos manifestemos
es un terrible retroceso es un golpe a
todos los logros de la revolución
tunecina y a nuestro derecho a
manifestarnos
tovar la protesta terminen disturbios la
policía usó gases lacrimógenos y cañones
de agua los manifestantes acusan al
gobierno de cortar sus libertades
estamos aquí para defender las
instituciones en la republica empezando
con el poder judicial que es el objetivo
de esta dictadura estamos aquí para
defender lo cambiante elena el año
pasado el presidente de túnez suspendió
el parlamento y disolvió el gobierno
hasta celebrar nuevas elecciones desde
entonces sawyer gobierna bajo varios
mandatos que sus oponentes tildan de un
golpe de estado el malestar va en
aumento debido a la detención del ex
ministro de justicia y opositor nuredín
biri a quien las autoridades acusan de
terrorismo las protestas coinciden con
el decimoprimer de la revolución
tunecina que inició la denominada
primavera árabe en países vecinos como
egipto libia yemen siria y bahréin
llegamos al final de este informativo de
ustedes gracias por su sintonía
[Música]